burger quiz la saison de trop vous est
présenté par nous nous croyons vraiment
que le nuage de tchernobyl s'était
arrêté à monaco oui c'est comme celui de
lusine lubrizol de rouen qui s'arrêtait
163 boulevard de verdun ar oui pareil
naïf
première info ce matin et ça c'est
terrible de la tomate quel est ce
nouveau virus détecté en inde après la
variole du singe on passe à la grille de
la tomate préparons nous à la suite
l'arrivée da syphilis du bigorneau prévu
pour bientôt
autant la variole du singe j'étais
inquiet mais là la grippe de la thomas
je me dis ça va aller ça va aller
patients avant qu'une tomate vous
éternue dessus ça devrait le faire donc
a priori c'est pas hyper compteur ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ça virus qui
touche principalement des enfants de
moins de cinq ans ça va être se
manifester par un espèce de syndrome
grippal de la fièvre des courbatures des
douleurs abdominales de la diarrhée est
un peu tout et cette éruption cutanée
que vous juste ici qui a un aspect un
peu comme des grains de tomates on parle
du virus de la tomate vrai ou faux il
existe un mouvement pour l'extinction
volontaire de l'humanité
malheureusement ça peut être vrai c'est
vrai tout à fait c'est la vhs emt ça se
prononce véhément blunt c'est la volonté
à rieumes en extinction mouvement qui
comme son nom l'indiqué donc voilà un
site les êtres humains ne plus se
reproduire afin de provoquer
progressivement l'extinction de l'espèce
humaine sympa
pour l'heure il n'y a pas trop de
raisons de s'inquiéter si ce n'est que
ce genre d'éruption peut-être visible en
médecine de ville votre enfant peut
avoir ça pas besoin d'aller aux urgences
de les voir votre médecin généraliste
qui a fait largement la sphère il a
peut-être que pied ma bouche et pas le
virus de la tomate et on peut manger des
tomates pas ce qu'on pourrait croire que
vous certes elle était d'accord sur tout
oui parce que la tomate est riche en
lycopène et la clique open c'est bon
plus pour la prostate je prends soin de
la prostate en mangeant des tomates il
ya des taux des taxes l'âme ces poissons
en 19 ans une tarte au chaud à
aux états unis je suis resté trois
semaines au même endroit non c'est quand
j'ai tourné j'irai dormir à hollywood et
que j'essayais d'aller chez une star
ouais donc je suis resté trois semaines
à los angeles et je suis rentré chez
george clooney avec un corbillard
j'avais repeint en rouge mais ils m'ont
foutu dehors le moule du pis jimi
hendrix bientôt exposer les cieux oui le
musée phallologique de ré qui avient ses
musées de la table et voilà c'est comme
ça c'est en islande à hollywood vous
mettez les mains comme ça dans du bitume
ballard tient au fait que le mec a pensé
à mouler son machin alors je ne suis pas
islandais bon gars en fait quand vous
êtes une énorme star et je souhaite que
ça arrive et ben voilà c'est parti c'est
c'est le musée grévin du chi chi jeu
j'ai sonné chez spielberg m'a pas laissé
entrer j'ai essayé de coincer wood smith
et les flics m'ont attrapé n'ont eu ni
mort ni de l'autre côté et donc j'étais
resté un peu longtemps sur place
j'ai noué une affinité que nous avons
concrétisé sa
jimi hendrix il y aura sa place ici
c'est comme avec sa guitare normalement
on devrait pouvoir reconnaître à la
forme dimanche qu'il était cochée allez
c'est pas tous les jours qui vous est
donnée de cuisiner pour quatre
inspecteurs des onco ne vais aller on
l'apprend cette opportunité louise et on
décroche se passe et on connaît le luxe
ne regardez surtout pas philippe
etchebest qui essayent de paix
déstabiliser
selon pas marché ça va pas commencer
aujourd'hui c'est bon
voilà et aujourd'hui au conseil de paris
on a eu beaucoup de mal à respecter les
temps de parole ils ont encore plus de
mal à tenir un conducteur que nous
pour voir si notre quatrième avait
terminé le temps parole de votre groupe
là non c'était difficile si si tout à
fait l'intervenant précédent non non
chronomètre la soirée du stade de france
c'est ce que raconte monsieur m'a parlé
que de ça depuis le début le mais non
mais moi je n'en parle pas c'est le
gouvernement qui parle de faux billets
moi c'est pas mon sujet les photos ce
n'est pas mon pas bon de vous éliminer
une partie de la réalité ce n'est pas
mon sujet enseignera tout je vois ça
manifestement c'est insupportable
franchement vous parlait tout le temps
c'est insupportable moi je vous le dit
c'est insupportable c'est le rire ou
vous exprimer de manière nuancée c'est
évident non mais c'est insupportable
je faisais déjà huit accords ont bien
entamé comme un changement de régime
dans le temps s'il vous plaît qui a été
réalisé par yale et bien vérifier dans
clarté c'était combien dix minutes au
total
vous savez très bien 86 but 62e gfr
[Applaudissements]